en quoi est ce que ces émissions phares
comme découverte incarne des valeurs aux
radiodiffuseurs en fait son mieux mais
avec les compressions budgétaires
actuellement on peut pas le faire autant
qu'on voudrait on a été obligé de
commencer notre saison trois semaines en
retard n'avoir que des reprises est
actuellement en période de grande écoute
on a une reprise par émission sont
quatre reportages
donc nous faisons quand même de travail
au niveau de la qualité et au niveau de
la quantité de notre offre
ça diminue et jamais on 21 ans a
découvert et je vis à moins cher à du
canada depuis 40 ans je n'ai vu que des
cycles de compressions budgétaires
actuellement doit être rendu à 600 ou
700 millions de dollars de compressions
budgétaires depuis que je suis à radio
canada je n'ai jamais vu ça et là les
compressions qui nous sont imposées
encore viennent dans cette vague là mais
à la fin de la vague
alors on est allé trop loin on n'a pas
assez de moyens pour faire ce qu'on
devrait faire et bien de faire ton
et
radio canada est une institution
culturelle d'une importance capitale
dans notre pays autant en anglais qu'en
français et cette institution là doit
être soutenu par les gouvernements
successifs qui ont qui nous ont encadré
nous devons avoir un réinvestissement
dans ce boire pour nous aider à faire
notre travail correctement
on parle du virage numérique il doit
être fait le virage numérique n'est ce
pas c'est important de faire mais au
moment où on devrait le faire
on a des investissements regardez on a
parlé de la presse tout à leur café la
presse quand elle a fait son virage
numérique
elle investit 60 millions de plus que
faisons nous nous coupons
et je rajouterais
et je rajouterais que si a du coup vers
nous faisons un travail remarquable avec
le web pour justement décliner nos
reportages sur cette plateforme on a
fait par exemple dernièrement un
reportage sur le web absolument
remarquable sur l'exploration et
l'exploitation possible avec les
conséquences environnementales
exploitation donc des hydrocarbures dans
le golfe du saint laurent et sur l'île
d'anticosti et ça a été déclinée sur le
web c'était formidable on a fait la même
chose pour rosetta et la petite sonde
fille là et qui entérine spatiaux suisse
on a compris la grande lac-mégantic
exact est également donc nous faisons ce
virage là mais nous le faisons avec des
moyens diminués et en plus ce qui serait
le fer de lance le moteur de ce
lancement la les jeunes on les fout à la
porte
et
alors il faut que ça cesse et que le
gouvernement comprenne que radio-canada
cib ici est une institution capital dans
ce pays et il faut nous soutenir
m
oui
on va
un score de vrais concessionnaires avec
des joints samedi matin
merci monsieur je me sens interpellé est
ce que est ce qu'on devrait
compétitionner avec des grands joueurs
comme voice
il va parler de vice d'en haut mais
pourquoi pas on devrait compétitionner
avec tout le monde et tout ce qu'on dit
c'est donnez nous les moyens on a un
talent et finit dans cette boîte
nous avions un talent infini il a été
éliminé mais donnez nous donnez nous les
moyens à james ward chasse on va faire
du très bon travail mais en ce moment on
est en train de nous garder c'est pas la
direction du canada aussi bis et qui est
en cause c'est le pouvoir qui nous fait
ça et c'est pas parce que chez les
conservateurs maintenant regarder ce que
les libéraux enfin avant c'est pas
nouveau non c'est vrai